die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis
guten abend und herzlich willkommen den
sport hat für sie norbert könig genommen
was sich gerade in afghanistan abspielt
ist so dramatisch und die entwicklung
sind so rasant dass wir ausführlich
dorthin schauen die themen dieser
sendung
taliban erreichen kabul die hauptstadt
afghanistans steht kurz vor dem fall in
großer eile startet die bundesregierung
eine rückholaktion sei
der opfer in haiti steigt bei dem
schweren erdbeben kommen mindestens 700
menschen ums leben
und trauer um gerd müller der legendäre
bomber der nation ist im alter von 75
jahren gestorben
die taliban sind offenbar die
afghanische hauptstadt eingerückt nach
eigenen angaben haben sie die kontrolle
über den präsidentenpalast übernommen
dafür gibt es bisher aber keine
bestätigung präsident ashraf ghani soll
ins ausland geflogen sein überraschend
schnell hatten die islamisten das land
geradezu überrannt zuletzt nahm sie die
wichtigen provinzhauptstädte masar i
scharif und sha la la bath kampflos ein
jetzt sind sie bis in die hauptstadt
kabul vorgedrungen und stehen vor der
machtübernahme im land katrin eigendorf
berichtet
us militärhubschrauber über kabul die
usa bringen ihr botschaftspersonal zum
flughafen amerika und seine verbündeten
verlassen nach 20 jahren das land es
wirkt wie eine flucht in den straßen von
kabul teilweise chaotische szenen als am
morgen klar wird die taliban rücken ob
die stadt vor beobachter berichten
bislang gebe es keine kämpfe im
regierungssitz verhandeln die taliban
über eine machtübergabe
das alles so friedlich bleibt daran gibt
es viele zweifel handy aufnahmen zeigen
wie die taliban in kabul ein gefängnis
stürmen und ihre kämpfer befreien aus
dem provinz metropolen die bereits
erobert sind berichten menschen von
gräueltaten vor allem an jungen frauen
aus herat erreicht uns die nachricht
dass taliban kämpfer verlangt haben alle
unverheirateten mädchen ab 15 jahren an
sie herauszugeben
präsident ashraf ghani versichert zwar
heute die regierung werde für die
sicherheit der bürger sorgen er selbst
so inzwischen geflohen sein immer mehr
menschen versuchen das land jetzt zu
verlassen doch das wird immer
schwieriger was wir nicht zeigen können
journalistinnen sportlerinnen die
zuhause sich verstecken aus angst auch
uns erreichen heute immer wieder
hilferufe von menschen die um ihr leben
fürchten die armee das haben die letzten
tage gezeigt ist auf sich alleine
gestellt nicht in der lage das land zu
verteidigen überall geben die soldaten
kampflos auf über den regierungsgebäuden
von kabul könnte bald schon die flagge
der taliban wie
katrin eigendorf beobachtet die lage in
afghanistan für uns schon seit jahren
kathrin haben die taliban jetzt faktisch
die macht im land übernommen so wie sich
die situation zur stunde darstellt sieht
das so aus dass die taliban die macht in
kabul übernehmen oder übernehmen werden
aber das kann sich wirklich nur noch um
stunden handeln ich teile auch die
möglichkeit dass es eine
interimsregierung geben wird für sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass haben die taliban
ja immer abgelehnt genauso wie sie
wahlen abgelehnt haben die taliban
wollen in afghanistan ein islamisches
emirat errichten das heißt afghanistan
wird künftig dann nach scharia gesetzen
funktionieren mit den entsprechenden
konsequenzen natürlich auch für
menschenrechte und konsequenzen auch für
frauen die sicherlich ihre
gleichberechtigung verlieren werden wir
haben jetzt schon in den gebieten die
sie erobert haben gesehen was das
bedeutet ich denke alle menschen die für
ein modernes und weltoffenes afghanistan
eingetreten sind müssen jetzt wirklich
um ihre sicherheit fürchten verlag für
diese einschätzung hat ein eigener
während die taliban in kabul die
kontrolle übernehmen sind die westlichen
staaten noch bei der evakuierung dazu
tagte heute auch der krisenstab der
bundesregierung
das personal der deutschen botschaft ist
an dem militärischen teil des flughafens
in kabul verlegt worden es gibt kritik
dass das alles zu spät passiere nicole
diekmann
berlin kanzleramt seit gut dreißig
minuten läuft von hier aus einer
telefonschalte mit den fraktionschefs
der bundestags parteien die linke im
vorfeld fassungslos ein solches desaster
nach über 20 jahren ist wirklich kaum zu
verantworten so viel tote zivile opfer
59 tote bundeswehrsoldaten 13 milliarden
euro versenkt desaster selbst
kabinettsmitglied seehofer benutzt
dieses wort für den einsatz heute in
einem interview und sagt weiter man muss
damit rechnen dass sich menschen in
bewegung setzen auch in richtung europa
das ist keine angst mache sondern eine
realistische beschreibung der situation
wir stehen vor schwierigen entwicklungen
ein versuch das aufkommende thema
flüchtlinge möglichst aus dem wahlkampf
herauszuhalten
kurzfristig aber geht es jetzt darum
menschen in sicherheit zu bringen
deutsche und afghanen die für die
deutschen gearbeitet haben kritik von
den grünen jetzt ist eigentlich für ein
echtes tun viel zu spät die
bundesregierung hat die ort kräfte im
stich gelassen ich hoffe dass wir noch
so viele wie möglich da raus bekommen in
verstecken wie hier in kabul hoffe sie
auf ihre rettung doch experten sind
skeptisch dass viele es in sichere
deutschland schaffen zu rasant die
entwicklung tempo mit dem die
afghanischen sicherheitskräfte jetzt wo
muss man sagen zu fallen sind und das
land haben den stich gelassen das war
nicht abzusehen transportmaschinen der
bundeswehr hier im niedersächsischen
wunstorf spätestens morgen sollen sie
starten gerüchtehalber vielleicht auch
heute schon jede minute zählt
und mehr über die aktuelle lage in
afghanistan erfahren sie gleich nach
unserer sendung in einem zdf spezial
viele versuchen aus afghanistan zu
fliehen fdp chef christian lindner
appellierte im zdf sommerinterview an
die bundesregierung auf der
internationalen bühne jetzt dafür zu
sorgen dass eine situation wie 2015 in
syrien sich nicht wiederholt im umfeld
von afghanistan müsse eine infrastruktur
aufgebaut werden um den flüchtenden
schutz und menschenwürdige umstände zu
bieten über lindners aussagen zur
innenpolitik thomas rechnet
christian lindner legt sich im
zdf-sommerinterview weitgehend fest für
eine ampel koalition seiner fdp mit
grünen und spd fehle ihm die fantasie
die union wiederum glaubt lindner werde
trotz sinkender umfragen ende doch vorne
liegen deshalb erwarte ich eine
regierungsbildung unter führung der
union wegen der des momentums und ich
glaube dass das eine sache der union
wäre dass weitere format zu bestimmen
also diese so genannte jamaika oder
deutschland koalition heißt lindner
rechnet mit schwarz grün gelb oder
schwarz rot gelb und positioniert die
fdp es gegenpol zu den grünen gerade
beim klimaschutz lindner hofft auf
innovation ist dabei gegen die förderung
von e-autos gegen ein ende des
verbrechers weil in den
verbrennungsmotor können wir auch
synthetisches benzin das mit
erneuerbarer energie in chile produziert
wird einfüllen und das müssen wir auch
den werbe millionen autos auf den
deutschen straßen im zdf verteidigt lind
nach außerdem das steuerkonzept der fdp
dass bestverdiener mit jahreseinkommen
über 300.000 euro besonders stark
entlastet wer ein hohes einkommen hat
zahlt allerdings auch mehr steuern
menschen die so ein einkommen beziehen
beziehen das ja oftmals in unserem land
nicht für sich sondern es das einkommen
ihres handwerksbetriebs aus dem auch
dann die wirtschaftliche substanz
erbracht werden muss zusammengerechnet
bedeuten die fdp-vorschläge ein defizit
von bis zu 90 milliarden euro für die
öffentlichen kassen wie das konkret
finanziert werden soll sagte lindner
nicht das gesamte sommerinterview mit
dem fdp-chef können sie um 19.25 sehen
in haiti sind mehr als 720 menschen tot
geborgen worden nach dem verheerenden
erdbeben der stärke 7,2 hunderte häuser
waren am samstagmorgen durch die
erdstöße eingestürzt viele menschen sind
verschüttet claudia bates
der tag danach inzwischen haben sie
bagger die helfen die großen trümmer
beiseite zu räumen und an überlebende zu
kommen helfer klettern unter den schutt
in der hoffnung noch jemanden zu retten
liga im südwesten dies ist besonders
stark betroffen knapp 100000 einwohner
die stadt die am nächsten am epizentrum
liegt zerstörung überall und tausende
ohne dach über dem kopf in zelten auf
dem fußballplatz das krankenhaus ist
überlaufen verletzte werden versorgt so
gut es eben geht noch sind sie hier auf
sich gestellt in der abgelegenen region
ist noch keine große hilfsaktion
angerollt
wir können die situation noch nicht
bewerten die lage ist sehr kritisch und
wir müssen unsere ressourcen aufteilen
und auch in andere stark betroffene
gebiete schicken
erst nach tagen wird man das ganze
ausmaß abschätzen können haiti braucht
hilfe von außen wieder und wieder wird
sie dem krisengeschüttelten land nicht
langfristig helfen
und er kommt zum sport und dort heißt es
abschied nehmen von einer wahren fußball
legende wird als einzigartiger torjäger
im gedächtnis bleiben dafür nicht sicher
gerd müller rekordtorschütze der
fußball-bundesliga und weltmeister von
1974 ist am frühen morgen im alter von
75 jahren gestorben
er war eine prägende figur in der
erfolgsgeschichte des fc bayern münchen
er war ein gesicht der bundesliga das
tor für die ewigkeit schoss er im wm
finale
1974 gegen die niederlande
der bomber der nation wie er genannt
wurde wechselte als 18-jähriger zum fc
bayern prägte mit meyer und beckenbauer
eine ära mit 365 treffern der
erfolgreichste torschütze der bundesliga
vier mal deutscher meister dreimal
europapokalsieger der landesmeister der
größte stürmer den das land
mit seit jahren an alzheimer heute
morgen ist er in einem pflegeheim
gestorben die fußball welt trauert um
gerd müller
einen ausführlichen nachruf sehen sie
hier im zdf um 0.50 oder schon jetzt in
unserer mediathek
überraschung im ersten sonntagsspiel der
bundesliga stark ersatzgeschwächte
mainzer gewinnen 1 zu 0 gegen rb leipzig
und patrick nielsen ist triathlon
europameister auf der langen distanz der
schwede gewinnt den ironman in frankfurt
am main hat regiert sohn ist der
strahlende sieger auf dem frankfurter
römer der schwede gewinnt die
langdistanz in knapp acht stunden vor
dem dänen mögen haug und mcnamee aus
schottland um 6.35 geht es für die 49
profis am langener waldsee los die 3,8
km beendet sein ganz vorne auf der 184
kilometer langen radstrecke ist der
animierender verfolger und dem
abschließenden marathon der stärkste
franz löschke ist in abwesenheit von
frodeno und lange als fünfter bester
deutscher verpasst aber die
qualifikation für arbeiten
am 19 oktober gibt es dann den klassiker
im pazifik dankeschön arbeit der
deutsche wetterdienst warnt vor schweren
gewittern mit heftigem starkregen und
hagel in teilen bayerns die weiteren
aussichten für morgen vor allem in der
nordhälfte sowie an den alpen zeitweise
kräftiger regen und gewitter im
schwarzwald bis zur oder aber auch
größere sonnige abschnitte starker in
böen teils stürmischer westwind
höchstwerte 17 bis 26 grad um 22 uhr
begrüßt die marietta slomka mit dem
heute-journal und jetzt direkt im
anschluss können sie hier ein zdf
spezial sehen zu den ereignissen in
afghanistan machen sie es gut auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]